let's take a look at some unusual moves
in the market today at least in terms of
what we normally see these stocks do and
I got to start with Google I know we've
been talking about Google law today but
it's worth talking about the shares are
in a record their up the most in one day
since 2008 these are the a shares Google
goog with an L on the end up sixteen
percent right now and really helping
contribute to the games that we're
seeing in the Nasdaq versus the S&P in
the Dow which are falling all of this on
the back of the company's earnings
revenue rising thirteen percent the CFO
Ruth Porat saying that the company will
exercise expense management and
prioritize revenue growth and the market
liking that commentary now because of
the game we are seeing in the stock and
the size of it today that means that the
company's two founders are adding just a
little bit to their network though Larry
Page and Sergey bring each adding four
billion dollars so eight billion dollars
total added to these gentlemen's net
worth today their total net worth by the
way each is around 32 billion dollars
that's including today's gain for the
year their net worth has each risen by
about seven billion dollars as we have
seen google shares rise by about twenty
percent other unusual moves today
include the move that we have seen in
Etsy and this one actually has a little
bit to do with Google this was almost a
throwaway line in Google's conference
call today developers like Etsy are
already seeing a boost in traffic as a
result of deep linking that comment
alone is causing these shares to search
by twenty-five percent but not really
that comment alone because you also have
to consider the short interest in SE
take a look at my Bloomberg terminal for
that we are seeing short interest in the
stock you seen it's gone up a lot
forty-six percent of this company's
float is sold short what that means is
when you see a big surge in the stock
you then have people who have sold it
short start to cover those shorts and
push the stock up even more so that's
one of the reasons why we are seeing
such an outsized gain and Etsy today
guys